all right let's get to the best and
worst part of space so every time Neil
is here he tells me something terrifying
about the universe that I end up
Googling cuz you ask me I don't come in
I know cuz I want to know I'm a prepper
okay I like to be prepared so it's
something we
call
what oh my God
oh my God I didn't know that was
[Music]
coming all right so you're welcome freak
me out well you know what In fairness
you're about to scare the hell out of
all of us so go ahead what's one thing
oh okay you want to know ways we might
die delivered by the universe okay so we
just brought back a sample from an
asteroid called benu This is an asteroid
whose orbit crosses Earth's orbit okay
any there it goes and any asteroid that
crosses Earth orbit will one day collide
with Earth it's just a matter of when
asteroid benu it will cross Earth's
orbit and we think it could hit us with
a one in about 3,000 probability in
2182 that's not far okay so and no it's
not farther and and the as is about the
size of the Empire State Building so no
it won't render us extinct but wherever
it hit would be really bad okay so so
but 160 years that's plenty of time to
find Bruce Willis
exactly no get him up there no there
plenty of time to figure out there's no
way to protect us from that
no
no no we we have no there are no why
don't you shoot at it no there's no
plans right now to deflect anything we
are sitting ducks and you know the
dinosaurs had they had a space program
they'd still be
here
I love you so
[Music]
[Applause]
much thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home